hey everybody its Gary Vaynerchuk so
everybody who listens to the podcast
I've been wanting to do this concept for
a long time I did a version of it not
too long ago a couple episodes of the
brown paper bags where we drink wine but
these three wonderful people are not
gonna get served free alcohol you're out
but I've always been fascinated by what
happens when you bring different people
together that are doing interesting
things and just shoot the [ __ ] about
what's going on in culture in the game
and I think a lot of people are in this
group specifically I think from what I
know about them from afar have
crossovers and and see certain things
the same way and then obviously have
their unique journeys and points of view
and so I've been wanting to do you know
there's this thing that I used to do
when I was first coming up in the game
in Silicon Valley where I met all the
hardcore Facebook's and Twitter founders
and Hueber founders and they were called
jam sessions where we would get together
at these conferences at like midnight in
a hotel room and for 3-4 hours just talk
about the game right if we would have
won tonight we would talk about
cryptocurrency right for sure we did
four years ago that's why I bought
Bitcoin four years ago so you just get
different ideas and thoughts about like
we would argue about who's gonna be big
who's not and so I've been wanting to do
this thing called pod sessions podcast
versions of the jam sessions and I'm
very excited I have three phenomenal
guests and probably one of the biggest
things that I want to get out of pod
sessions is also an opportunity for me
as my career change is to use my
platform of the attention that I'm
amassing to put other people on that
also sometimes have bigger audiences to
me different audiences to me or emerging
and are doing interesting things that
have caught my eye normally through some
digital connection or the eye of
somebody on my team's digital connection
so that's what we're doing I'm super
excited about it you guys are the three
that are helping me pop the cherry of
pods legends they've been here and so
why don't we introduce ourselves let's
start with the ladies so we go ahead hey
I'm sweety I'm from LA originally from
the Bay Area and I'm an art
and recently just um released my single
I see growing us one really well and so
what's really fun for me on this is that
you literally di mean you're like yo
you're always in the room with all these
dude rappers why don't you bring a girl
let's get the ladies in here I'm like
she's right this year right and you know
she said right here love it let's keep
it going with our job yes husband I mean
that husband wife of a boy with no job
who works for you yes um real name is
Claudia Ashish Rai from New York live in
New York one school in New York love New
York never want to leave everyone keeps
tell me I should move to LA but I would
rather die thank you sweetie about the
fight like we have a conversation piece
I like can seduce me when I'm there like
on the second day cuz the Sun is like
[ __ ] right freeze but it's too slow for
me yeah you're starting to get weirdly
slow I might have stirred to China it's
just the traffic so a lot of people
listening here between your amazing
husband who I know very well because he
works at Vayner on the influencer world
the girl with no job and the boy with no
job so first of all which account
started first oh mine yeah very
important everyone should know yes so
growth no job is a monster mom now
everybody does know so girl with no job
is a monster Instagram account we'll get
into the origins of that but going well
you're super happy all going very
pleased it's good and love yes yeah
cipher sounds I also love New York I
don't want to leave
DJ comedian and everything in between
yes and uh I don't have as many
followers as girl with no job that I
just know nobody just shrunk my my my
ego just yeah the early when I follow
I'm gonna get there yeah I got it you
gotta choose something right yeah the
next time all right let's go back around
and create the two-minute origin story
like tell me about your early days what
got you going how'd you how you became
an artist I played your single on repeat
all the way down on my winter vacation
and so I especially like when anytime
people are talking about pasta and
seafood dishes I get excited okay that
was my favorite if I was back to the old
days that I used to listen to music with
a temp and rewound
there it's a lot easier now that just
slide the finger back but you're born
and raised in LA know born and raised in
the Bay Area got it yeah so what took me
to LA is um so I was riding since I was
like 14 years old writing writing like
maps Yemen so I wanted I've been wanting
to do this however I didn't have the
resources I didn't have the plan yes so
I went to college yep San Diego but I
was like okay this is a B market city
yeah um I need to go to a more and shout
out to San Diego that's a B market isn't
it I think that's a compliment you need
to go to LA of course I wanted to go to
the best college apply to USC got in yep
I'm graduated and still didn't have the
resources so I was like you know what
I'm gonna do car revs that's what I was
known for it and I was like someone's
gonna see these car wraps I was doing it
couple of them went viral I ended up
meeting my manager and ever since then
we've been rockin he was like you know I
know about nine months ago yeah so for
all of you not in the know car wraps is
like a genre that's super interesting
like it just makes so much sense now
that we have cameras and the ability to
record anywhere like I don't know I
actually think my vlog is a car wrap
like the amount of content dailyvee is
that's at the back of my car is a
majority because we're so busy like I've
loved following that whole scene and
there's been multiple people that have
popped off from car wrapping did you see
somebody popping and decided I'll do
that too or was it just kind of know so
I had recorded a couple in my car and I
was like you know consistency and
familiarity is like
important with your viewers and your
audience so I was like I'm just gonna
stay in they're not cozy in that zone
does it feel like a booth yes my boo his
name is Bruce you named her car
Bruce yeah go go no job how the hell did
that happen
it happened how does she know job well
actually it happened because I had a job
I went to NYU I was like so bored
everyone at NYU is very career-oriented
New York narrative the NYU part made it
so much better you wouldn't never leave
like I literally never die in this city
100%
do you even travel outside of it well I
was just in Mexico and it was beautiful
and everything but I couldn't wait we
got home I get it yeah it's just I'm not
a traveler I don't wonder
so 365 days a year you spend 350 - in
New York City 363 honestly never want to
Mexico for two days literally literally
no joke usually 9/10 you're spending 350
days in the city yeah and you consider
Queens and Brooklyn the city yeah okay
yes it doesn't ever the five boroughs I
don't but you you you consider all those
yeah you don't consider Jersey the city
I mean I spend huge amounts of time
there but I would really hate Queens
doesn't everyone so yeah I started this
blog I got an internship in fashion PR
and this was like free Conde Nast
getting sued and now having do pay your
interns yes you should it's the right
thing to do and I don't think people
should pay anybody but that's a whole
different story if you're giving them
actual opportunity I'll explain that
later I know it's an unpopular statement
but yes Heather I'm not paying you
anymore
so I got this internship it was six
years ago it was unpaid it was like
ungodly hours it was just horrible
everyone was like super [ __ ] and like
mean and skinny and like fashion I was
just like I was I'm the opposite of that
I'm so cool everyone loves me and like
it was just I was being so put down
there you know um so I started this blog
called girl with a job it was like on
tumblr it was like the only way I knew
how to make a website back then was on
the job with a job and I basically it
was more like a diary I used it as a
platform to like talk [ __ ] about
literally harvest beasts you need to
look right up there that is me investing
in Tumblr great investments huge I mean
like that was like that Twitter and
Tumblr were a year before Facebook like
yeah that's what put me on like tumblr
is forever in my heart know if you have
tumblr followers you got followers every
they're so loyal and like as like a 18
year old you knew nothing about computer
it's like I can make a website without
having to like I don't have a host or
like things that I know now it was just
great as young people like most of you
are all young but like doesn't it feel
weird that there's like 17 18 year olds
that don't know what tumblr is yeah it's
like the lack of tumblers like existence
does that [ __ ] with you
well no okay are you excited about vine
too
yes me too OkCupid very excited okay so
I started this blog it was really like a
diary absolutely nobody about it even
like been like no one read it I'm dating
them no actually we are dating yet so I
forgave him for not reading it in
analogy for like people to me we're not
reading and I didn't she got fired cuz I
was terrible they hated me I hated them
and I was like so nervous that someone
was gonna find my blog so I got fired I
changed it for accuracy purposes to girl
with no job took to Instagram a long
time ago we're like the only person
maybe I was a freshman in college so
like six five or six years ago okay
we're like the only person I knew on
Instagram was like Perez Hilton like he
was like the first person that's rich in
peace yeah rest in peace no here's the
good news Perez can flip it up and like
this is great about the recall like any
it's all about executing properly if you
look at who's winning like it's really
funny don't ya well Smith's doing
Will Smith is about to take over cuz
he's logging mm-hmm like you know like
he got out of not being as relevant
anymore make it 25 million 30 million a
film is exciting mm-hmm but like once
you've got money you want relevance
again mm-hmm and I and and you know what
it takes humility that's why he's a
beast he's humble enough to do it right
I think Perez like fine I'll make it
prediction it was putting ethos vine 2
is gonna be the platform that Perez
rises like a [ __ ] Phoenix respect
like since high school I'm done well of
course cuz you read his blog every day
every day in high school how many - 2009
dominated and how you can have such
success and just like end up where you
are is just like there is a well he just
released a video on YouTube saying that
he was an addict and he didn't say - why
really he said not to drugs or alcohol
but he just has an addictive personality
and I was just waiting for a what he's
addicted to and yeah it's a face tattoo
I'm gonna lose my [ __ ] yeah I got fired
go on the job you feel - Brandon on
social really the point of getting on
social was like to drive traffic to this
website that I had understood where as I
kind of just fell into like
entertainment culture on social and
never even really pick back up with the
blog I just fell in verse like a branch
top off moment like one did like um what
did you post I posted a it was like a
picture it was a snapchat actually of a
girl like you know girls put their
thighs like up on the beach and like hot
dogs yes yeah and so it was like actual
like what you think you see and then it
was actually a girl's fingers like we're
telling to be her thighs and it was not
a beach it was like her computer and
she's at work you know like mr. Ambrose
really yes and that just went yeah I'm
away you what yes okay I'm I got like
6,000 followers in one day and we'll you
did you know been at this point I guess
I did now dating dating and did you text
and be like what the [ __ ] yeah nobody
were dying we were just like on my phone
scrolling and like refreshing and what
was he what was he doing with his life
at this point this is just me problem we
were still in college right then okay I
don't remember too much of you better
story man Oh from the Bronx originally
moved to Long Island in high school
that's where I learned how to speak
white
how quickly did you pick it up very
quickly very quickly it's easy to pick
up
well here's a why people love this is
today wire yes the airhorn
popper yeah and why people love the our
Kelly ignition remix I once played on
repeat drive from Wine Library the
liquor store to Atlantic City and back
huh do you love that song yeah like you
like no I'm saying in the hood it's it's
okay it's a good our Kelly song no it's
well resided in the white community
favorite our Kelly song thought is too
many
real talk everybody will talk you know
real job of course Kelly doesn't know
that that's a you must have grow up
around I grew up my people yeah I want
them out of college 97% yeah like yeah
real talk is like a deep deep cut no
hook at the end he goes out Melvin so
yeah so um so I learned why DJ and I
learned why Ahlers DJ I managed to get
good at tennis no no no you never went
you never not that way you got too close
well I don't do any sports
that's laureate none you're not athletic
you now hate me no I don't know I don't
like how I keep going I'm not being
athletic no problem as long as my dad
died when I was young and I'm summing
this other comedian that whose dad also
died when he was young I think that has
a big part of it like really like
somebody get it father
you know it's funny my dad worked every
minute influenced nothing of mine cuz we
were immigrants I never saw him yeah it
just were kids in my neighborhood were
thrown INRIA
fault like there's a million vet you got
a cousin that was yeah yeah that's a
musician yes yes that's a super heavy
into music I started DJing for with this
guy DJ raised he introduced me to
Funkmaster Flex of course I start
interning at the radio station in 97
worked for you in 1997
yeah amazing yeah it's perfect yeah
super mess so uh years and years and
years work for no money and just kept
climbing climbing climbing eventually
got the morning show which lasted seven
years and huge run for you yeah I was at
the radio station for 17 years in
between I'm doing a DJ for little Kim an
are that star track which is Pharrell's
label I ain't are that Rockefeller like
I've done a lot of things that you're
too when you bring up little kids when
literally this morning think I sometimes
think about my day when I'm like brush
my teeth hour and just thinking about it
like I was like you know I was thinking
about you like talking about like the
female rapper thing and I was like man
there was a point where I think Foxy
Brown was literally my favorite artist
in the world for like that that little
48 seconds of that someone would talk
and biggie were dead and I was like
[ __ ] up and like [ __ ] it Fox he's my
number one sorry anyway just when you
said Kim cuz that was the battle of the
time those two is kind of like fun
so nonetheless so you're in between
there are DJ on the Chappelle show I
mean Dave Chappelle then I'm funny on
the radio so people start saying you're
funny you're funny sounds like alright
people keep saying funny let me try to
Congress comment on the radio and I've
listened to yours like it was more like
a fan improv funny like you were getting
off the hip oh like I'm gonna do a set
right yeah but people kept saying like
should I do
well I just started doing comedy as to
make money like I'm gonna produce a
comedy show I didn't think I was gonna
do comedy it's just like people keep
thinking I'm funny associate I'm I think
I'm funny I'll show you how funny I am
give you money
so I did this night called don't get gas
it was one of the hottest comedy nights
for like five six years and from that I
started like doing stand-up yep and then
at one point I was just like okay am I
gonna do this for real and I left the
radio station and at you know 39:38 with
a pregnant wife decide to start a whole
new career good for you man Here I am I
mean I've been doing stand-up let's say
eight years ten eight years but like for
real like where's my bread and butter
like four or five years all right let's
go back around the table this is segment
that I just made up five seconds ago
claim what am i what am i obsessed with
like what is happening right now in
culture or end or your life that you
were obsessed with sweet I am absolutely
obsessed with social media like the
whole [ __ ] thing yes okay let's rank
them in order your of your obsession
number one every day every other app has
to die you can only live there it is
Instagram great okay I love like I love
Instagram but I'm starting to love
Twitter and he's not figuring out what
works there it's my mouth figure out
what works we're different
mm-hmm you found this new womb it's like
you found the dead you've always had in
the kitchen be like wait Dunn's kind of
[ __ ] cool like it can I do in here so
Twitter is emerging Twitter yeah and
what is emerging what else um that's
about it so those two mm-hmm so you're
obsessed with twitter and face and then
Twitter definitely okay good
I mean no job girl yeah I'm obsessed
with everything I could talk about
literally anything for but till the end
of times the number one thing that you
were obsessed with right now like
stories and live-streaming like in real
time content you know yes like I use
stories more than I actually post on
Instagram these days yes just because it
feels super natural for me because
that's like I've started on snapchat a
while ago yes so just like letting
people know what I'm up to at all hours
of the day yes and then seeing how many
people look at it and what's going on
that's saying over like the verified
accounts that watch my stories respected
verified makes it better
yeah worse that blue check is [ __ ]
status money
not money hooking up and other random
[ __ ] that has been happening because of
that B check is [ __ ] batshit crazy
we're starting to abuse it though yeah
like getting themselves verified when I
just don't feel like they deserved it
what 90% shouldn't be obsessed I'm
obsessed with all the dope TV shows that
are out right now and I want to make
make make TV show you want to make - yes
what's your number one dopest freshest
TV show I mean listen I can't break it
down I pray categories no I'm saying I
got it you can I'll give you the airtime
to say every one of them but then you're
gonna have to have a final [ __ ] door
and pick one right now like hand mate
Handmaid's Tale yeah it's sad you don't
say it but then I also love stand-up
specials you don't sound like I'm Segura
yep no necklace right Hailee's you know
what's so funny it's just pattern
recognition is exactly what HBO did in
its early days like comedy is always a
pillar
yeah just like sports just like music
fashion comedy is such a pillar of our
society and what I love right now about
Instagram and you've got to give a
shout-out to vine cuz comedy absolutely
played out there yeah and definitely
obviously now Netflix and podcasts for
that matter
I think up for a lot of people comedy
has reemerged as an obvious pillar
whereas if like for example you guys
talk in your age group like seven ten
years ago like six seven five five six
seven eight years ago it wasn't like
comedy was that in our face now you know
like you go back to myspace with Dane
Cook and you know the tail end of Adam
Sandler CDs and like the Jerky Boys on
you know I'm old as [ __ ] so they bring
that up like but like there's these
moments work whether it's comedy or
sports or music they pop up in reminding
us how important I think comedy is
having a moment yeah Kylie used to be a
super slow burn you had to be on the
road for 15 years traditional to get
recognized yet and now there's so many
different ways to see it and so many
different ways to do it is definitely
popping off do you feel like do you feel
native to doing comedy on Instagram does
that come natural to you know do you
know I just I struggle with that because
I really love
live stand-up in a club and I feel
that's getting overshadowed by people
doing it on social media do you feel
like do you feel like so it's funny for
me when I hear that I feel like that
everything is tried and true like it
will net like to me I think it's
addition to yes like oh I think we're
having way too many conversations up and
you know or in right of and right I
agree
like like ever like I think one of my
favorite things about young people is
that everything's in play now so I love
hip-hop it's crazy to me that there was
only one move in hip-hop when I grew up
in there right early to mid 90s which
was if you're not hard you're out right
and now I literally think like like lil
yachty would have got his face beated
right or ii like like like like you
can't dress like you can't do that now
you can do everything anything anything
and i think as long as you've got skills
which i think is important all right
fine good girl with no job what is your
ambition going forward i think you're in
a very unique spot from my perspective
okay you have a lot of leverage yeah cuz
you have a big audience yeah you are
we've mentioned tumblr we've mentioned
snapchat
I think you're you know I'm giving you
smart cred off your husband being smart
I'm sure you learned everything from you
so you're clearly smart so where do you
sit on the hmm paranoia of is Instagram
gonna be the most important thing for
the next 12 months right 24 months 48
months and 72 months how else am I
spread us out what am I doing with this
you know how are you thinking about this
unique moment where 99% of people
listening are trying to get to a place
where they could live on the back of
these platforms you are in that book I
don't know anything even he and I don't
know but I know what your account is
yeah which means to me that you easily
could live your life with that as a
media property but you're also smart
enough to know there's a vulnerability
and so many people have been burned on
being one-dimensional just YouTube's
one-dimensional just Twitter MySpace we
mentioned earlier like Tila Tequila
should still be relevant yeah if she was
able to be relevant in every sea change
read people get emotional and say well
this is the thing
I don't like this new thing but that
everything's gonna kill you unless you
embrace it yeah and like I literally
wake up every day and I'm like afraid of
the fact that I don't know what the cool
new app is and any time they meet like a
twelve-year-old who knows who I am I'm
like what do you do on your phone like
when you're laying in bed what apps do
you like what don't you like I'm in for
a while I like lived in fear that
Instagram is on its way down and that
snapchat was where I was at so I put
like so much time and resources into
building a successful snapchat which now
just bit me in the house cuz I had a
successful snapchat and like nobody
cares anymore why why are your numbers
showing you that nobody cares any magic
my numbers are so really strong just
from like a like a hole oh yeah like a
cool perspective I just don't think that
people are thinking that snapchat is
cool anymore and as a user like I'm so
loyal to snapchat I think it put a face
to my brand yes and my brand wouldn't be
the same if it weren't for snapchat so
anytime I feel like if I see something I
want to capture my hand literally just
goes to snapchat and that's starting to
change because I'm recording more on
Instagram stories now that I am on
snapchat because there's a bigger
audience for me it's like a built-in
audience it already exists and it's just
they're doing such a better job like for
me as I use it as a broadcasting
opportunity snapchat does not help
creators whatsoever find new audiences
Instagram is like putting my stories on
the suggested paycheck it's helping me
find users who would have no idea who I
am sorry podcast so you can see that she
looked at her phone something clearly
was on the phone either yeah no so bill
is not my fingers right now and say with
all the leverage you have now what would
be the number one next move that's
outside of your norm of being a content
creator in okay there's two it requires
a one a and then step two because I need
to just build out my digital portfolio a
little bit more before I want to move to
like traditional media yes so I want to
have like a bigger and better YouTube a
bigger and better everything yes so I'm
more well-rounded stuff by the time I
get to like where like a dream scenario
is like a young edition of the view and
where we talk about things that young
people care about not that like yep
Rosie O'Donnell cares about I need to
have like a full portfolio I'm sold um I
love Rosie I think she's so smart I just
I have I don't know why I the view is
always my example for what's wrong in
modern media but layers I'm a 23 year
old woman I don't feel like I'm
represented by
it's a port but I don't think I'm
represented in daytime what about the
real it's closed it's better okay I
don't feel like I'm represented in
modern media especially daytime media
where there are people my age or close
to my age talking about these that I
give a [ __ ] about the overt respect for
linear television in this room is
disgusting next sweetie like what what
do we want do we are you in the mindset
you know you know that you're just
eventually you and the team are gonna
put out the song that changes the
narrative of your career is that where
your minds at in like are you in the
mindset of like I gotta keep working on
the work putting out good projects and
that inevitably one of those like to me
it's amazing to me how interesting the
music game is to me like I struggle with
with finding a way that people pop
outside of either the album or the
single song being it's a very it's a
very straightforward game which is that
is the moment that changes so many
things it's either that hook that song
or that or that cameo or that album are
you are you just thinking hardcore let
me be about my craft let me keep being
better at my craft let me keep putting
out great songs and and I'll take it
from there
I would say that's one of the factors
yeah however what's constantly on my
mind is marketing yes because that song
or that hook or that whatever it is I
even make sure that I'm always
capitalizing on my audiences it's going
to show that when I do release that it
touches a wide range of people so that
it can pop off because without that
without marketing like without thinking
about that every day you just you're
missing the opportunity of like
expanding your audience and you're at
the mercy of other people exactly if
you're so like if I'm always thinking
about like widening my range of
whoever's like viewing would you like my
work yes that's awesome
that's the number one thing on my brain
because if you're not doing that then
you might how much music can we expect
from you in the next 12 months gut feel
you may not have the answer for that but
intuitively how much music can we expect
from you what do you think I would say
maybe two or three projects and our
projects like six
twenty-nine songs or three songs and I
would say in 10 to 12 songs got it three
projects in the next year two to three
Wow nowadays that's not even a lot
that's a good amount back in the day
where you put our album out every year
and a half two years now music it's
flying out well we have the microwave
generation no I know but that's why you
made some friction good I mean my big
thing is as many songs as you have in
you you need to get out yeah because
you're not at the mercy of somebody at
the radio station or any or the label
like this is phenomenal
yeah throw that [ __ ] up like if like
this is the most democratized music has
ever been there's some kid right now
listening like in Ottawa Canada who's
gonna put something on soundcloud that's
40 seconds away from poppin yeah ya know
like when I see girl went viral my song
um someone in Dubai sent me the picture
of them on the beach with my thumb in a
ludus like what yeah once you press that
button and the music is you press send
the music goes across the world
instantly exactly I remember back in the
day and I don't want to sound old but
I'm old like you oh I used to go to
Japan and we would play I play a lot of
90s hip-hop because they were so far
behind yep and then as I'm watching the
technology grow how world music has
changed everything has changed
information is moving at a totally
different look that's why you're saying
you're so into marketing because you
know the music is only half of the
battle exactly how many people put out
music you have to be on top of that
other half where like back in the day
artists were just artists it just may
you know there was some more more
entrepreneurial but they just made good
music and then they had hopefully it
would go now you're still on top of it
no because audiences and fans aren't
interested in the artists who who is the
typical celebrity right they're
interested in the artist who is like
your everyday person and who is
accessible yeah yeah
who do you want to most work with give
me two or three names just like work
with this business or musically or
whatever you want um I don't want to say
I'd want to work with dr. Dre only
because I worked I I worked
I saw his documentary she was crazy
Jimmy Iovine
and they're mad Sciences I like Drake I
like what he's done with ovo and his
branding he's constantly marketing and
I'm real quick I apologize I think what
Drake is really smart with and I thought
it was what I think one of the best
moves of the year and was the humility
he decided to show in the commercial
with his dad right like people you
understand like people like this is all
high school this will always be high
school exactly like the second you
figure out somewhere for most people
between sophomore and junior year of
high school where you're like oh [ __ ]
right if I make fun of myself and I
laugh at myself with my friends they'll
stop picking on me like understanding
the moves I think Drake understanding of
anthropology and psychology of like if I
put a national commercial for my
beverage on where I get clowned and my
dad gets the girl like that is smart
there's not a lot of people who have the
humility in the common hip-hop because
you were saying like everyone wants to
be okay you want to be hard
Rach that's why Drake wins cuz I'm sure
100% and he's awesome and helps hello
it's Rachel this hardcore beard do you
think he's soup is hotter like one day
the creek is hot because I break rig leg
I feel like treecko's I got the American
dream like he was on Degrassi the injury
[Music]
like him but I'm gonna know why do you
know what it was like the dark show
things were yeah yeah what were you
watching it on like Nick at Nite yeah
literally
keep going what was he he's the dream
he's American dream like he just went
from that do you know any of the other
kids under Grassi no and now Drake is
like drink I'm any wonder always I'm
gonna go with the thong yeah would you
you know her name what uh what's the big
North Star for you in the short term
okay next thing you'd want to sell what
I did I kind of left music you know
doing this comedy thing what I realized
and what I discovered is that combining
them I'm creating my own lane so I
combined my hip hop friends and all my
history with comedy yep
so I do an improv show at UCB where I
get hip-hop artists to come tell
real-life stories and then me and a
bunch of improvisers make up a whole
show on the spot I love that you know
saying and then I do a Dave Chappelle I
DJ like when we did Radio City was there
almost a whole month I remember I DJ
from cracking jokes while I'm DJing so
my job my goal now cuz no one else can
detai and do stand-up and if they're out
there I'm gonna like no like I'm not the
greatest comedian I'm very good DJ
combining it no one's in my lane I love
it and make my own path I love it
what can I do for you let's go back
around the other way you first
man um I would say help me get to as
many followers as she has
but you already do that because I watch
all your videos and learning everyday
how'd you come across it do you remember
your stuff mm-hmm
just on Instagram just people posting
all your stuff and what kills me about
you what I love it when someone catches
you in the hallway or after you speech
speak or something and they ask you the
question and you give them the
straightforward answer and they like
blank and like they want like this trick
and you're like no get in the trenches
and work your ass off for years no ten
years you know saying and just keep
going they're like yeah
how do you know know I answered you
already Lee I really do need a yeah but
t-shirt yeah because that's usually the
answer to almost everything I said yeah
but yeah it's like dude he told you the
answer like I love that
straightforwardness I appreciate it yeah
girl no job what can I do for you mmm
well I do you know Indy going yes I
don't have to go I would love to also
know Andy Cohen okay just like a
personal favor and I would also just
love for their text Eric Wattenberg shot
set it up yes coffee or drinks
I would you prefer drinks obviously i
flourish with the drink
what would you order oh it depends where
we go I would want to come off as like a
lady but also cool so probably like a
like a vodka soda you know got it what
do you think Andy would order oh for
sure like an old fashioned or like a
wish every drink says gay yes
yeah and who's Andy's favorite music
artist John Mayer very good keep going
now we will actually yes we need I would
love to sit with you for 30 minutes yes
and just like discuss the social
landscape like I'm fairly certain I know
what's going on yes in the digital space
but maybe I'm wrong okay do you want to
just triple check yeah like he's gonna
double check that I'm doing everything
right like man's gonna be there
sweetie what can I help you with two
things go ahead so I've seen the
interview they blow a buggy yes and I
thought you mentioned Captain Crunch yes
I want to do something with them you
love Captain Crunch I love Captain
Crunch
every black hey look captain black girl
loves Captain Crunch are you black
everybody loves him
White's love cats right you know okay
like you Mike boy let's put that on the
docket
yeah second thing a second thing I want
to learn how you built your team
I loved the interview you did with a
bogey I feel like you shed so many gems
and I feel like building the correct
team around you is really important
we're like expanding like just me you
know while I'm wrapping up and I
apologize everybody's gonna feel it that
I'm like wrapping up because I got the
entire company in four minutes that I
have to address and so I'm gonna bounce
out of here but this is a good thing to
end with because I think everybody
listening will get value out of this so
I appreciate the last thing you said
there's several things that matter in
building a team number one the biggest
mistake people make is they think people
work for them instead of them working
for that / team member I think the
biggest reason I've had success is I
genuinely think I work for Tyler and
Jake and Tyler and D rocky it's my
responsibility as the North Star the
last line of defense to create the
framework for them to flourish not for
them to like be at my beck and call and
I'm the leader and so it's a really
interesting mindset but I think you
start building actual teams when
everything that's [ __ ] up is your
fault as the a the number one and and
that everything that's working is shared
with them so for everything's broken
with us I take on with me it's not Andy
or niraakar Tyler's fault it's my fault
and everything that's working is a lot
me I believe that but I also think a lot
of them picking up on those nuances
that's number one number two all three
of you have the following amazing
opportunity I mentioned it early and
it's really ironic but the girl no job
story I believe we're living in an
incredible time I believe that your if
you're a young here let me use you as
the example if you were a 14 year old as
if you're an 18 year old young woman
that has enormous aspirations to be in
the music business that interning for
you and the team for six months and not
getting paid and I know we talked about
earlier but if it's for somebody who's
got something going on and honestly
anybody who's bigger than you and and
whether that's more album sold more
songs downloaded more more experience
what have you but ever back to the Dubai
thing all three of you have on
terrible day 100 psychotic fans and not
psychotic weird bad I mean all in [ __ ]
with you heavy they're all about you of
those hundred people I'm gonna say for
me too it's not a big number I mean
people that are like in Portland Oregon
right now that if you DM them and said I
want you to follow me around they would
be in the room right now and photography
me and video me and post that in me and
make more time they would rip their arm
off get on a plane and fly and be part
of you team the fact that in the same
way anybody can pop now anybody can make
music that you can build a team before
you have the finances to afford the team
because it's an even trade
it doesn't even trade like a job that
way that what does the government see it
that way listen yeah you have to abide
by laws and if there's a if there's a
state law like I would want that but I
think there's a minute because it's
under two Vayner right as a human I
don't know rent consult your lawyer not
like like the reality is is that here's
my thing the amount of women that aspire
to be you right now
like I know a lot of them right they
would I don't know what else to tell you
I genuinely believe that Lisa
Schwartzman
writer for Sam in Millburn [ __ ] New
Jersey right now will get way more
[ __ ] value for working for free for
you for six months she's about 99.9% of
the [ __ ] she could be doing I totally
agree and if you want to email me that
has to play out yeah you have thunder
scene guys in 1947 going to college
wasn't the right thing to do it was
getting a vocational skill like [ __ ]
changes mm-hmm no you wanna hear
something crazy
not only do I think in 20 years the
version of you is not gonna pay I think
the person's gonna pay you for the right
to even be in your circle well she said
I think so okay but I'm telling you
right now do you not be [ __ ] people
who want to be exactly what you can
teach them yeah are gonna pay four
thousand dollars for some [ __ ]
[ __ ] horse right now or some like so
building a team first you work for them
period end of story from now to the end
till you put that [ __ ] star in
Hollywood on the ground and the cement
you work for them it's a big my
shift and most people don't get it and
that's why most people don't [ __ ] win
number two take advantage of the moment
there's a lot of [ __ ] kids trying to
build up their comedy I've built interns
who are now stars stars came from my
camp I get it
so I just they're out there I think that
that's the other thing and literally
it's like an Instagram story or it's
gonna post or tweet of like looking for
five huts
like I don't have much to pay right now
but I'll show you the world I'll show
you the insight it's real it's very very
very real and for everybody listening
you know some of you don't have the
money and you think you can't compensate
and you think you're doing the wrong
thing if your intent is right so the
reason I'm never scared of paying
minimum wage or having resident or an
intern is I know that I'm always capable
of settling the score if they're so
[ __ ] remarkable if they do so much
greater than what they got paid I can
always do something down the line and
you know you're up to something and
you've got something going on you can
always settle the score in the fourth
quarter
so if you have the right intent I'm not
trying to steal from them right I'm
trying to get my value good
relationships are when both people get
value right the end all right one last
thing you can leave them with and I
gotta go one last thing for everybody
listening what should they know what do
you say at all what do you want me
personally I don't know how anyone else
did I know how I did I get in the room I
work for free I show my value then
people don't want me to leverage that's
always how I do it what can people find
you at Cypress sounds CI pH a and the
word sounds please Oh a truTV I got a
new show on truTV with no job Instagram
Facebook Twitter all that stuff Claude
with no job you know building my
personal brand respect doing a live show
for my podcast doing a live show at
Caroline's just look me up you know I'm
everywhere um sweetie sawa et ie
Instagram and Twitter and you know car
wraps - doing my first show in Turkey
Istanbul next week so nice whatever you
can do out there
kids social media take advantage of it
love it guys thanks for being on the
show yeah past please leave some social
comments for me feedback to what you
think about the format I'm excited as
[ __ ] is this
I got lucky all three of them did their
thing this was good this load we may
have to take this on the tour like
person and Andy have their little thing
like now it is here I mean the four of
us in Carnegie like Oh No
murder me murder murder
you